You know that feeling when hours
disappear and work feels effortless?
When you look up and realize you've
accomplished more in two hours than you
usually do in eight? Here's the secret
nobody taught you. Flow state has a
recipe. You don't need to meditate for
years. You already do this accidentally.
Playing video games, texting your crush,
binge watching shows. You just never
learn the on switch. The two-minute
protocol elite performers use daily.
Clear your workspace completely.
Do five double sniff breaths through
your nose. Long exhale through your
mouth. This is your body's built-in
chill pill. Pick one tiny thing to
start. Write one sentence. Send one
email. Then say out loud for the next 90
minutes, "Nothing else matters but
this." Your inner critic. It literally
shuts up. While everyone drowns in
notifications, you'll surf mental waves
they don't even know exist. Your flow
state is waiting. Time to flip the
switch.